on débute ce journal avec le résultat de
la primaire de la droite et du centre
est le premier constat c'est un succès
en terme de participation
bonsoir wilfried bonsoir haussmann
effectivement avant de regarder en
détail les résultats un mot sur cette
participation plus de 4 millions de
votants c'est presque deux fois plus que
lors de la primaire de la gauche en 2011
et parmi ces votants plus de 250000 sont
yvelinois un succès qui a amené benoît
hamon député socialiste a posté
d'ailleurs un commentaire sur twitter
exercice démocratique réussie aux
électeurs de gauche de jouer les 22 et
29 janvier fin de citation et puis
concernant les résultats à présent la
vague françois fillon at-elle submergé
le département alors regardez tout
d'abord à nouveau ces chiffres nationaux
on le rappelle françois fillon est plus
qu en tête 16 points d'avancé sur alain
juppé et puis vous le savez cette
élimination de l'ancien président est
nicolas sarkozy voici à présent les
résultats dans les yvelines françois
fillon est encore plus haut que la
moyenne nationale quasiment 49% et
nicolas sarkozy qui lui s'effondre on
rappelle aussi tout de même qu'alain
juppé avait le plus grand nombre de
soutiens politiques dans ce département
on imagine le réveil difficile ce matin
pour tous ses soutiens devant cet écart
de près de 20 points avec l'ancien
premier ministre de nicolas sarkozy
écouter et karl olive c'est le maire de
poissy landais premier soutien d'alain
juppé dans le département et c'est même
lui qui avait ouvert le dernier meeting
au zénith et puis juste après vous
entendrez aussi une autre réaction celle
de bruno myle yens et c'est le président
du modem dans le département des
yvelines une formation est clairement
engagée pour alain juppé également le
seul engagé en 2000 en 2013 avec alain
juppé avant même qu'il est annoncé sa
candidature
je suis un compétiteur je n'attend pas
la fin d'une course pour annoncer lors
des shows et j'en suis fier et on va
poursuivre cette belle compétition car
c'est une compétition
ce n'est pas un combat et par rapport
aux résultats que vous avez pu découvrir
sur l'ensemble de de l'hexagone où il ya
un raz-de-marée de de françois fillon
bien on peut se satisfaire en tout cas
qu alain juppé se soit hissé malgré tout
en finale et qui sera un concurrent
projet contre projet
pour la deuxième mi temps si l'on peut
dire dimanche 27 novembre
je ne pense pas que le meilleur candidat
pour battre marine le pen demain ce soit
françois fillon c'est plutôt alain juppé
qui lui réunira plus de monde autour de
lui
si la gauche est elle est en train de se
et en train de se réunifier loin de là
on voit bien les candidatures qui
partent dans tous les sens donc une
forte probabilité que la gauche ne soit
pas présente au second tour il nous faut
vraiment un candidat à la fois
rassembleur bourquin président de tous
les français et qui soit en capacité de
battre marine le pen preuve d'une
certaine fébrilité dans le camp juppé
néanmoins l'annulation du meeting prévu
ce soir en présence de jean pierre
raffarin à versailles une autre réaction
à présent ou plutôt d'autres réactions
celle des soutiens à nicolas sarkozy
tout d'abord celle de david douillet le
patron des républicains dans les
yvelines s'est fortement impliquée dans
cette campagne il n'imagine d'ailleurs
pas un retrait complet de la politique
de l'ancien président et puis juste
après la réaction de fleurance à bagua
elle est présidente elle aussi mais de
la formation des jeunes républicains
dans les airs et il encourt pelouse du
ruisseau
qu'il soit en politique ou pas peut-être
que le fait de ne pas y être lui
prodiguera plus d' écoute et de
crédibilité vis-à-vis des des français
il avait le meilleur programme de cette
de cette primaire celui qui était le
plus lucide soit les toutes les
problématiques de la france et c'est
vraiment dommage que il était sanctionné
par sarko baisse systématique terminée
dans la déception à l'effort il ya un
peu un sentiment d'inachevé car ton
amertume mais bon on ne retiendra que
merde cette campagne qui était très
belle enthousiaste et on a fait plein de
rencontres et c'est ça qu'on retiendra
essentiellement son bilan à lui a coûté
cher peut-être oui enfin vous savez
françois fillon était le premier mythe
de nicolas sarkozy donc ils ont quand
même un dîner en commun donc les
voiliers c'est un peu compliqué de
pouvoir juger uniquement sur sur le
bilan parce que sa fille dorénavant on
doit pas perdre une minute et tous
rejoindre françois fillon et s'aligner
derrière ce mandat pour vraiment incarné
l'alternance forte dans notre pays a
besoin
et puis à noter aussi la réaction du
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier lui aussi aux côtés de
nicolas sarkozy qu'il imaginait sans
l'ombre d'un doute l'emporté il s'est
dit ce matin totalement derrière
françois fillon il a tout mon soutien et
toute ma confiance
la surprise est donc venue de françois
plus de françois fillon fera sa force et
aux propres quand on n'imaginait pas une
si large victoire au premier tour
exemple avec suzanne blanc c'est la
première adjointe de montigny le
bretonneux elle est responsable du
comité de soutien local m ne doutait pas
un seul instant de la présence de la
fréquentation
françois fillon voit là elle ne doutait
pas de sa présence au second tour mais
pas avec un tel écart écoutez là autant
à un moment donné les gens le voyait
plus comme l'ancien premier ministre
et petit à petit en vraiment ils se sont
appropriés sont son programme ils ont
presque oublié qu'il avait été premier
ministre
non pas que ce soit une tare loin s'en
faut mais il n'avait plus ce côté ancien
premier ministre et d'ailleurs
le côté le candidat le candidat françois
fillon avec son programme
c'est une vraie belle surprise une vraie
belle surprise mais il faut savoir
raison garder et tant que le 2e tour
n'est pas fait voilà on ne crie pas
victoire tout de suite
donc ça donne nicolas sarkozy 3e alain
juppé deuxième françois fillon premier
et quelle place pour les autres
candidats une place presque anecdotique
un exemple avec bruno le maire
présentait comme le troisième homme en
début de campagne il s'est effondré et
tout au long des différentes semaine il
est cinquième au niveau national et même
sixième dans le département des yvelines
des yvelines voici l'analyse de philippe
benassaya c'est le maire de bois d'arcy
soutien de bruno le maire c'est un
effondrement soudain au lieu le maire et
fait figure un petit peu comment vivre
sans être désobligeant mais il fait
figure un petit peu de bonheur
voyez donc mais ça ne suffit pas dans
une campagne électorale il faut aussi
séduit un exercice des primaires
ouvertes c'est à dire qui est
extrêmement compliquée lorsque j'en suis
pas fan je les lis et je les dis on je
suis pas fan parce que forcément vous
fait rentrer des stratégies
politiciennes de gens qui ne sont pas de
droite forcément de gauche l'extrême
droite ou du centre ne serait ce que des
gens qui ne veulent plus de sarkozy
des gens qui veulent plus de hollande
des gens qui ne veulent plus de
personnes vont qui viennent voter à une
primaire et look qu'on oubliait de
soutenir la corrida et pour terminer ce
tour d'horizon dans les yvelines tour
d'horizon des résultats ce dernier
tableau il concerne uniquement la 10e
circonscription c'est la circonscription
du député jean-frédéric poisson qui
était également candidat et il
enregistre son meilleur résultat au
niveau national il frôle l et 5% et il
atteint même les ronces % dans sa propre
commune de rambouillet jean frédéric
poisson qui devait venir ce soir en
plateau finalement il est resté sur
paris pour rencontrer les représentants
des deux finalistes
car lui aussi il entend bien négocié les
quelques voix qu'il a réussi à engranger
pendant la campagne
eh bien merci à vous une frise pour ses
analyses